هو سيد بظهر نريد ان نقرا معك هذا المشهد
في تطوراته الان الخاصه بما قاله بريجوجن
عن اسقاط مروحيه
للجيش الروسي
صحت هذه المعلومات ما الذي يعني ذلك
[موسيقى]
ان جنود فاقنر مدربين على اعلى المستويات
ولديهم خبرات عاليه خبرات عاليه جدا حتى
اولئك الذين كانوا مساجين سابقا ومن الصعب
الوقوف ضدهم
خاصه اذا استمروا في التقدم والخضوع
لاوامر بريغوجين
وفي راستوب ليس هناك قوات من الممكن ان
تقف امام قوات فاجنر
الحرس الوطني والحرس المتواجدون هناك هذا
غير كافي لايقاف قوات فاقدر يجب استرداد
القوات النظاميه من الجبهات هي الوحيده
التي ممكن ان تقف امام قوات فارنير اعتقد
ان المشكله ليست في في بريجوجل فقط اعتقد
ان لدى جنود ق حماس عالي وهم يقوموا
بالخضوع لاوامره بغايه الرضا هم مواطنين
وطنيين جدا ولكنهم يكرهون وهم اعداء
للنخبه القياديه الفاسده من وجهه نظرهم
وهذا هو واقع روسيا ان بريجوجودين له شهره
كبيره
لا تكون هذه
قد لا يكون هذا انقلاب بل قد يكون هذا
بدايه لثوره او معركه شعبيه سوف نرى ما
يخفي المستقبل